one more time for the christmas tree
[__] christmas already what the [__]
and you leave your house and it's like a
little cool up and also you see like a
santa claus in front of rouse and you're
like really
it's [__] christmas time already and
like you don't know like you go early
that's what i got the one by mine he
wasn't fully dressed yet like you could
see like
he just had the top he's like [__] the
jeans it's only
it's only the first week we're just
gonna break out the hat and the bell
but it's [__] christmas time this
just confirmed it right now
and i haven't done dick [__] black
friday i don't go shopping till the 23rd
you know what i'm saying
that's when i'm ready to go when
everybody's all done i go down and i
[__] cut it quick too
because now you go to ralph's and they
got those cards that you could just buy
[__] people right there
right at the supermarket you go
christmas shopping target
olive garden [__] costco whatever the
[__] they eat you know what i'm saying
what would you rather do walk around a
[__] mall or get somebody a gift
certificate
to the [__] olive garden stupid
right there you're aroused you're
reading about [__] kim kardashian
dumping the [__] guy
and right there there's a stack of
[__] cards right there you know toys
r us right there
jeffrey 50 and you don't have to deal
with nothing a christmas card a [__]
signature
and a handshake like a [__] you
know what i'm saying
you ever shake somebody's hand for
christmas when you don't give him a
present
like you walk in you don't even know
that there you're like oh [__] merry
christmas like a
mother and you hold their hand tight
like doug i didn't get you nothing but
because sometimes he's just [__]
broke and you just gotta show up and
that's [__] embarrassing
you ever just show up with like one gift
and there's 80 [__] people there
and you're just spinning around like a
top merry christmas merry christmas
merry christmas
then they try to give you like an
honorary gift like they bought something
for a cousin who didn't show or
something
it's like a pink shirt and you're like
oh great i was looking for [__] water
something i'm saying